your first six months you didn't get any
deals and then suddenly there was a
switch and Charlie manifested into a
beast and you started selling five deals
a month making 10 15 a month how many
deals have you sold over the last sort
of 12 months 22. part of being
successful in business is just actually
doing it we're also in the middle of
setting a land deal so how much would
that give you in commission if that goes
through 40 000 pounds 40 Grand but what
you just said there is genius you might
get 100 no's in five yeses most of my
deals that I've sold have probably
through the academy so this is a proper
business for you now
thanks for coming to my house to share
your success as a property entrepreneur
how you doing very good thank you for
letting me come here so your big
strategy is deal sourcing yep many
people watch my YouTube videos and they
see me talk about fine deals package
them sell them to investors make two
grand three grand four grand you can
make 10 grand a month doing this
starting with no money and sometimes it
sounds a bit too good to be true and
people are skeptical and other times
people got loads of questions about how
do you find the investors how do you
actually sell it how do you package it
what about contracts so in this
interview
your real life case today because you've
gone from basically nothing how much did
you have when you got started I started
with two thousand pounds 2 000 pounds
and what were you doing at the time I
was actually currently working for a
friend from the Rugby Club doing
Marquees but previously before that I
went to University studied Sports
coaching cool how much did you spend
going to you know I think it was about
000. and then when you finished you know
you then ended up doing training with me
yep I got a phone call off of your dad
yeah saying I hope this
yeah he spent a lot the money on this
training and it has I mean how many
deals have you sold over the last sort
of 12 months 22. 22 deals yeah so on
average just a couple of months it took
me about six months to actually get into
it properly sure once I've got my feet
on the ground uh mate definitely
building relationships with agents
landlords uh and then obviously the
network how many are you selling now I'm
selling but three to five deals a month
okay cool that makes sense yep and
you're charging on average three
thousand pounds three grand yeah so this
is a proper business for you now yes not
a side Hustle No full time in property
yeah and how old are you I'm 24. so talk
to me Charlie about why you chose deal
sourcing and then I want to walk through
your first deal one I didn't have much
money to invest into say rent to rent
rent service accommodation rent to hmos
I needed some cash behind me so the
quickest and the not the easiest way but
the quickest way for me to do that is to
go out find the invest find a deal
package it up and sell it and then
obviously we get paid up front
uh contracts and all that are in place
and then partner them up and uh that
that an investor takes the deal right
and you're charging about three grand
yeah so I mean on average we sort of say
if you're if you're selling a deal like
I know you I need sort of wide range of
different types of deals but if you're
if you sound like a brr for example buy
refurbish your Finance or just a buy to
let about two percent of the purchase
price yeah I sort of go buy if you if
you're able to on a BRI especially if
you're able to pull your money out after
the remortgage probably sell that
between four and five thousand pounds
yeah we're also in the middle of setting
a land deal great and that's normally
about two percent so how much would that
give you in commission if that goes
through that goes through that'd be
forty thousand pounds 40 Grand yes in
one deal and then that's split between
three people yeah so but still it's a
good yeah yeah isn't it yeah it's like
12 13 Grand yeah yeah where are you
finding the investors who are buying all
these deals well this is it actually and
the academy does help you with this I
mean most of my deals that I've sold
have probably through the academy but if
it's not
I go to networking events so let's say
you go to a networking event yeah let's
say you're a you know a business
networking International meet and
everyone gets an opportunity to stand up
and give like a quick yeah snapshot
quick 20 seconds as to what their
business is there's rich people in the
room and anyone can go to these meetings
this is the thing people say oh you know
how do I find investors go online and
just search property events you know
business networking events and book on
yeah you can go for 20 pound 30 pounds
have a dinner have a breakfast and now
you've got an opportunity to stand up in
front of 30 40 50 people who are all
business professionals who are all
investors and you can pitch I think part
of being successful in business is just
actually doing it oh 100 taking action
is massive I mean
like you say these networking events are
20 pounds 20 pounds 20 pounds but
realistically you could earn three grand
off that even you might even meet agents
there who will one day pass you
properties every time something comes
available will give you that property if
you gain a good relationship with that
yeah I mean where my R patch is we
um
I go into the state agents and have just
have a chat with them sit down even if
I'm not even even if they've not got
anything I'll go in there and have a
chat just because I guess it's building
that Rapport let's say you're an
investors an event that like like where
there's a bunch of people and you stand
up and say that I'm a deal sorcer
selling three to five deals a week I'm
in this area
if you want to have a chat coming at me
now and let's say you have out of the 50
people 10 come and want to speak to you
and five people come and say oh so what
deals are you sourcing that sounds
interesting how do you turn
a bit of Interest into someone prepared
to actually pay you three grand for a
deal to be honest I just find out what
they want right
um I wouldn't really talk about myself I
guess I talk about what they want and
what their needs are and where they're
looking right and then I'd probably just
leave it like that and then if we can
get their number
right then speak to him on a one-to-one
basis and uh what you just said there is
genius though because a lot of people
would go to a networking event trying to
sell a deal whereas you're not hunting
you're farming when you go to a
networking event if you've got a deal
and you're trying to sell it to somebody
then you're a hunter whereas a farmer
will go to a networking event with
nothing to sell you go you farm and you
say hey this is what I do if you're
interested have a chat people come and
they're interested and you as you just
said ask them what they want take their
details then go find it 100 great so how
are you finding these deals let's say
someone comes up to you and says I'm
looking for a below market value
property or I'm looking for a apartment
block or they tell you what they're
looking for how do you go find that I
guess when you're in your patch and you
you gain relationships especially with
agents agents is probably the easiest to
find because they're on the High Street
yeah
um
find out what they've got see if that
property that the agents got matched up
with
the investor and if that if that's the
case then obviously try and get that
deal secured package it up and send it
to that investor or a massive one that
I've actually recently been getting it's
getting close to landlords
I mean I've obviously on open rent I've
gained some good relationships on there
I've even spoke to them on the phone for
about an hour at a time just just having
a chat with them seeing what they've got
talking about their current properties
and then it's Word of Mouth one deal
that I sold that was in central London I
did speak to her for about a month and
it just gave her a call seen how she was
as soon as she got anything else she
then gave my number to a landlord friend
and now I'm in contact with another
landlord what was your first deal that
you sold it was a buy to let actually in
King's Lynn right I think I remember
this do you how much was it
the purchase price on top of my head I
can't remember I think about 170. and
what was unique about the deal why would
someone pay you a fee it was it was a
little bit not tired but needed a bit
work done to it uh and it was HMO
already licensed right uh I only sold
that for two thousand pounds yeah just
because it was my first deal wanted just
to make a bit of money help someone else
who obviously took the deal on and uh
yeah that makes sense though it was just
a house you negotiated presumably a good
price yeah yeah I think I'm not 10 000
pounds off at the boat and obviously the
market back a year ago was quite high
right so properties were going over the
asking price yeah yeah you found the
seller that wanted Quick Cash yeah you
knocked 10 grand off the price yep it
was a good rental property with lots of
you could rent it out room by room five
bedroom HMO yep why would the investor
not just go straight to an agent why
would they go to you and pay you a fee
to find them a deal yeah well a massive
one is and some of these investors do
not have the time right some of them
might be just business owners in other
businesses but looking to get into
property as well to put their money at
work in property because they know
property will go up or if they want to
invest into rent to rents they're
getting more cash flow right yeah so
main one is probably I guess from an
Investor's perspective if they're
working as a lawyer yeah and they're
making 100 a year they've got money they
want to invest yeah going out on a
Tuesday rainy afternoon to potentially
have agents cancel on you at the last
minute getting exempt for them they're
having to pay stamp Duty definitely
about a mortgage broker fee they're
having to pay lots of fees and the
person that found the deal negotiated it
packaged it up presented it on a golden
plate with a red ribbon on it for the
investors to just go yeah I'll buy that
is that not worth three grand I think I
think I no I generally think it is just
because the amount like I'm happy to
jump on Zoom calls with investors as
well to go through the deal to make sure
because people massive one is people
buying to people yeah 100 if someone
jumps on the phone call with me I'm a
bit like don't we know you but this is
why I jump on a zoom call and I'll talk
to him what they want show them the deal
if I have already got it secured show
the due diligence package to PowerPoint
that I've got and then they can see me
read me as a person and I guess that's
another way talking of you as a person
yeah what gives you the right or the
credibility yep
to get paid three four five thousand
pounds to find a property investment
when you yourself are a young guy how
old did you say you were 24 24 young guy
24 just finished uni yep never been a
property investor don't own your own
portfolio why would someone pay you I
get why they'd pay three four grand but
why you I think the main one is because
well what I've paid to get educated and
got the knowledge true you're
professional exactly and that not
everyone knows how to do the numbers on
rent rents brr's
stuff like that and that's sort of worth
it and you running around doing the dog
dog work yeah
some people just don't want to do that
like it's and I'll be honest a lot of p
a lot of deals you get more no's and
yeses 100 right I mean you might get 100
no's and five yeses like that's just
reality and that is and when someone's
constantly getting those some people
might not like that probably don't have
the discipline for it discipline's huge
obviously especially with rent to
service accommodations and rent to rent
you've got to gain relationships with
landlords and agents and know exactly
what you're doing because there are a
lot of people out there who do mess a
lot of people around who don't pay
landlords which is slightly annoying for
the people who are doing it properly
and that's why we get those but you've
got to stand out make sure you've got
credibility and it is hard hitting going
out getting deals whether it be rent to
rent whether it be by refurbished
Finance flips land you're going out and
you're putting offers forward you
negotiating and you are getting a lot of
rejection oh yeah and as deal sources we
have learned and been trained as well
how to not take it personally and just
okay next but a lot of people like an
ordinary person a normal job they'd pick
up the phone they'd ring a landlord or
they'd ring an agent and they'd get to a
lot to cheeky off or go away and that
would ruin their week whereas we hear
that every day oh yeah I mean yesterday
was quite a bad day actually
10 deals fell through I mean man 10
deals I mean it's not the end of the
world obviously because we just keep
moving forwards that must have been like
a block of apartments or something yeah
it was yeah I was gonna say surely not
yeah yeah no no that's the block of
Apartments yeah yeah but still it's
disheartening yeah it is and it's it's
not because of anything bad is just
because I think the landlord just wanted
tenants that's it yeah but you struggled
a lot to begin with I remember month
after month after the deal with you
um on The Mastermind I haven't got a
deal yet it's closed that's not
happening what's going on and it took
you quite a few months before you
started actually seeing success oh yeah
six months of probably did you want to
quit I mean it came into mind but no
yeah no I I I don't like to quit never I
think that's just where I've come from I
mean I play a lot of very sporty very
like come from playing sport for for
many years
um no I don't like losing right it's not
in me so you were determined to keep on
going yeah what changed Charlie
your first six months you didn't get any
deals and you're on the academy you knew
arriving all the calls and the mentor
and the support and then suddenly there
was a switch and Charlie manifested into
a beast and you started selling like
five deals a month yeah making 10 15 a
month and in the last six months now or
so maybe six seven months yeah yeah
you've been consistently winning every
month what changed
I tell you so go back six months ago
also well about probably about eight
months ago we I mean I sorry I
probably hit a brick wall in a way
because I won't get myself out
and like I say stay around the people
who do who are in the game and asked
them one bit advice I'd say give that
ask as many questions as possible to the
people who's doing well right off that
and because I was just sat at home
trying to make money try and make this
work I weren't in the environment yeah
so I say I got myself in the back in the
environment right going to more events
going to more networking events asking
more questions and then
get showing people that I've I'm out
here doing it yeah and then and then it
will just yeah it's snowball success
doesn't it Snowball Effect because when
you get one deal your first deal is your
hardest not only have you done it once
and it gives you the confidence and you
have the know-how but also when you go
on the academy groups and you're like
hey I've done this deal and everyone's
like way cheering you on but now you
kind of put yourself on the map yeah and
then people oh could you find me a deal
could you find me a deal what percentage
of your investors that have bought from
you would just say you said most are on
the academy what would you say the
percentage split is rough split
I'd probably say
I'd probably say 70 30. okay so it's
pretty high percentage yeah yeah oh yeah
just because
I came from that Network so I
that's I guess that's where I've made
friends yeah as well as investors what
would you say has been your biggest
lesson over the last 12 months I'd
probably say get yourself out there and
take an action 100 and having good
discipline yeah what do you mean by
discipline like the amount of nose you
get don't just quit right just keep
going maybe like you I mean in the back
of my head I know this is going to work
and it is working and I just got to keep
going what does your dad think about
your success now I mean they're proud
mom and dad are proud they they know
that Mum said to me
a while a few a couple of months ago
said
to be to be honest I I thought you'd
quit did she wow just because I think
she probably would yeah because I mean
when you're making not really much in
six months it's a bit like
come on what what's going on it is it is
but if you keep going
you'll get over that barrier and I just
said look this is gonna work this is it
I mean they believed in me they invested
in me did they pay for the training they
paid a bit bit towards it oh that's why
I spoke to your dad yeah because I think
you said to me my dad's a bit worried
he's skeptical he's invested in some of
the training and I phoned him up or he
phoned me I you phoned him I gave you
his number yeah and I phoned him and I
think I put his mind at rest a little
bit
no I just said very I remember just
saying to him you know look Charlie's in
good hands we're going to take care of
him he's got all the support he's got
unlimited mentor and he's got everything
you know just so you know I think he's
going to be successful we wouldn't have
had him on if we didn't think so and he
was just like all right thanks for the
call you know so have you paid it back
yeah you paid him back yeah that's good
oh yeah and he's seen the money coming
in yeah yeah I mean I'm quite secretive
with them I don't like to get too
excited yeah I because if I get too
excited I might mess things up yeah and
you want to think you know what let me
just save that money buy some houses
yeah yeah I know I'm not don't want to
spend any of it I want to reinvest it
100 yeah exactly you're not going to go
crazy it's a business isn't it I haven't
won loads of money I'm gonna Splash it
up but you've changed your thermostat
100 my mindset's different yeah I talk
about this money thermostat what does
that mean to you knowing how money works
yeah
knowing how to
add value to gain money and then
reinvest it yeah so you're not trading
your time no no you're exchanging your
value for money yeah yeah a lot of
people I've bought deals off even people
on the academy they'll find a deal and
I'll be like that's an amazing deal how
much you want for it and they're like oh
and they feel almost shy because they
know that I kind of helped them find the
deal they were on a training program it
took them an hour but I'm like you don't
get paid for your time you get paid for
your value oh 100 if I'm gonna make 100
Grand I'm happy to give you five grand
at the beginning when you obviously made
them pull their faces it's like is this
real yeah but you just gotta be you've
got to be confident in what you're
saying is that that's in when talking to
anyone you've got to be confident in
what you're saying you've got to believe
that you're worth that and people buy
into that do you think anybody
can be successful with the right work
ethic
yes
yes no what could stop people the nose
the nose can massively stop you but
that's a mental thing right yeah so you
think that they've got the potential too
but it is the case of whether they can
cope with the rejection no 100 just
because if
if uh obviously no offense to anyone but
if you're weak-minded and things get to
you quite easily
probably not for you you probably can't
be making 20 grand a month doing deal
selling yeah because you're gonna have
to take hard calls but you don't think
you can learn how to do that you're not
think like but we gave you you know the
scripts to say and how to deal with it
and the processes and the procedures and
you know trains you to expect the
rejections we trained you go for no
every time you get no you know imagine
that you're gonna have to get 10 notes
before you make 10 grand so every time
you get a no you're thinking well that's
one step so I think do you don't think
you can maybe maybe you don't but maybe
you can program yourself for Success
yeah I I guess so I mean obviously the
script and everything I remember looking
at that and thinking I did look at the
outfit right okay that's sort of it but
you make it your own you learn from that
and I guess once you've learned from
that and you you put it into your own
script
I mean this I don't script's good but
don't always go off the script yeah you
can't be reading it word for word no no
you've gotta it's like I think it's like
driving you learn to drive you this and
this but then you just you just become
second now yeah learn the scripts but
then just play with it and make it your
own yeah and just put it into
conversation yeah yeah that's it I mean
just like this interview isn't it yeah
how did you do in school got all C's so
all right but I never really liked
school never really academic which is a
struggle yeah
yeah
you know yeah I did a bit of a bit I
wouldn't say naughty but like to mess
about yeah and are you proud of what
you've done in property yes what's next
what's next I guess just really I guess
now invest my money into
rent to service accommodations that I've
got in the pipeline ready what have you
got in the pipeline what deal are you
working on right now so we've got a
block of flats in the pipeline nice
um and I've got a cup one rental service
accommodation how many in the block 15.
nice big thinker what's your experience
been like working throughout the academy
really good just because I mean the
massive one is your network 100 and the
people around there I mean sometimes
obviously you can call up you guys and
ask for advice or whatever whatever but
you can talk to
anyone on that Academy chat and say look
I just need a bit of advice can you
answer this question what's your
thoughts on this and people will just
help you and I feel like that's massive
in property in its own property
obviously I don't really know that other
businesses but property I do feel like a
lot of people are out there to help a
lot of people I feel like that though
because of the property community that
you've come from maybe a lot and it's
massive definitely yeah but I think some
other property communities developers
clubs networks whether it's Builders and
you know Chartered Surveyors accountants
and and they they
I hate other people's success yeah which
is wrong which is wrong because this
business is mass you collaborate a lot
yeah yeah I mean co-deal sourcing
incredible way to make money what what
is that coding sources say if I had the
deal you had the investor
uh we'd come together match the deal
with the investor
and we've split the fee perfect like
that I mean I don't have an investor for
every single deal if if it did I'd make
a lot more money but when you co-deal
Source 100 is one incredible way to make
money and the academy as well there's a
lot of people yeah hundreds and it's
like the WhatsApp group alone being able
to just post oh I need an investor for
this anyone could anyone got anyone it's
gold oh yeah 100 I mean a lot of times
I've chucked deals in there and just
someone's messaged me saying yeah I've
got to investor for that doesn't sound
what they're looking for
obviously send it over see what he
thinks if you want to go ahead let's do
it well Charlie massive respect on your
achievements I look forward to seeing
you continue to win and I appreciate you
coming down to my house and sharing your
story brilliant thank you thank you for
having me
foreign
[Music]